tous
plus jamais ça il faut il faut avoir
bien conscience que le nucléaire est en
europe la première source d'électricité
décarbonée
la première après celle hydroélectrique
et nous avons besoin de ces sources
pilotable l'écart bonnet qui sont les
seuls qui peuvent réellement des
déplacés est remplacé à long terme
les sanctions possibles les centrales
fossiles que sont les centres et les
centrales au gaz
[Musique]
le
le geste de couper la centrale voilà
c'est un geste symbolique et forcément
ils vont le faire avec professionnalisme
et surtout avec un peu d'émotion
[Musique]
m
toute la journée a eu son lot de
d'émotion ou qu'elle même quelques
larmes d'ailleurs et on est dans la dans
le devoir de mémoire
[Musique]